malgré le développement du numérique
vous êtes encore nombreux à préférer le
livre papier au ebook et ça se voit
puisque les librairies indépendantes
fleurissent à Tours surtout depuis la
crise covid littérature bande dessinée
manga chacune a trouvé sa spécialité
Laura Chauvet les a rencontrés
elles sont 14 à Tours ça peut paraître
beaucoup mais pourtant les librairies
indépendantes perdurent l'arrivée du
Ebook n'y fait rien cela fait 30 ans que
la librairie le livre fonctionne très
bien c'est plus compliqué aujourd'hui
parce que les supports sont il y a de
nouveaux supports par rapport à il y a
25 ans ou 30 ans par exemple l'image qui
est dominante il y a des glissements
vers les questions numériques etc mais
pour autant il y a toujours des gens qui
sont attachés à l'objet livre tenir un
livre en format papier entre les mains
est très important pour certains
lecteurs ils ne sont d'ailleurs pas
prêts à se tourner vers le numérique
c'est la poésie du coucher c'est
vraiment se toucher là qui est que je
retrouve pas j'ai essayé le numérique
tout de suite j'ai abandonné parce que
je n'ai pas cette sensualité de là pour
acheter des des livres en format papier
parce que je cautionne pas tout ce qui
est libre en numérique ils sont nombreux
comme lui chez les fans de BD à trouver
que le numérique est inadapté au 9e art
le papier survit la pandémie lui a même
filé un coup de main indépendantes leur
épingle du jeu suite notamment à la
visibilité qu'elles ont eu pendant et
après la crise covid la reconnaissance
le passage en commerce essentiel
qui a été très important
signe que le marché se porte bien de
nombreuses librairies ouvrent leurs
portes dans l'agglomération Touran leur
secret pour éviter la concurrence
choisir une identité qui leur est propre
concurrence oui puisqu'on est certain
effectivement à proposer les mêmes les
mêmes ouvrages mais on a chacun nos
identités et si les gens viennent chez
nous c'est aussi par rapport à nos
identités qui on est voilà moi je sais
que si les gens viennent ici c'est par
rapport à mon choix de vivre c'est
certain mais j'ose espérer que j'y suis
aussi un petit peu pour quelque chose la
personnalité du libraire inexistante sur
les plateformes de vente en ligne une
véritable concurrente de nos libraires